vous avez vu qu'on a entendu le petit le
collectif métissé j'aimerais vous nous
disiez quel est votre tube de l'été ça y
est là on rentre dans le tube de l'été
l'étude sur lesquelles vous avez dansé
saïda c'est quoi elle a gagné son procès
contre le mec qui disait qu'elle avait
copié le bike tarn et shakira shakira ne
me signer dauphin moment je sais pas
danser quitte jamais appris à me
regarder sur la tête de ma mère ce que
c'est votre caméra côté ouais encore à
côté une fois de penseurs et la mairie
va se rend à côte et quand est ce que
votre tube de l'été vous car on n'avait
pas préparé pour cause d'algues on dit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allez c'est parti entre au co j'aime ça
j'aime bien ce look là il faut se lâcher
là c'est pourquoi vous l'algérino d'esma
sites aux noms
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
oh
à gérer n'est ce pas chez nous si ça
repasse cet été si vous êtes en chine et
pour le tour c'est mais vraiment vous
êtes ailleurs c'est comme ça
détaché
sinon tu as des nouvelles de jean yves
new passé comme ça que ça se danse à
ckoi vous c'est quoi alors moi c'est un
peu plus chic que benjamin c'est pas
difficile par action ce look metronomy
2011 assez bien vendre electro
alternativ
[Musique]
normalement ça vous mettez ça au début
de soirée la ligne à faire chacun peut
voir c'est au beverly hills un groupe il
m'a dit non il m'a dit qu'il était au
moonlight ce soir c'est cool ça vienne
bien tu aimes merci pas de délire ça
c'est de l'électro internet
j'aime bien c'est quoi on parle et
esseuler vacances c'est monsieur vélo
mais sa mère
et ça passe
présent me balade à sebha la nasa ces
accès au tout prix go to go balada c'est
l'autre c'est quand il s'appelle la boue
ce tableau lima je connais des échéances
et l'accordéon
au lycée
ouais
à celles-ci là ça lui rappelle le
portugal là ça y est là elle est
repartie au portugal
[Applaudissements]
on aura toute la communauté portugaise
regarder sont là bas ils sont à fond ils
sont serrés comme des saints les
embrasse merci oui bonsoir jean millet
ou jean-mi alors il a très mal au dos
non mais c'est vrai il a très mal au dos
aujourd'hui on embrasse jean-louis alors
moi c'est les sommets des tropiques
[Applaudissements]
saïda et au club c'est comme ça c'est
parti je vous rappelle que de bas il y
aura l'aquagym à 10 heures avec saïda
djeghbala tirer ses bras pour le tir à
l'arc
je rappelle sur la tête de ma mère moi
j'étais au à dire ma mon frère avait il
m'a vraiment séduit mais au tir à l'arc
et jamais tir à l'arc de m'a dit mon
frère
non mais c'est arrivé je me retrouve à 7
heures du matin faire du tir à l'arc
allons jouer avec vous quand je suis
revenu très fort on tient alors c'est
vrai ah ouais ça fait qu'on va c'est un
concours de tir à rossi ballon dit à moi
j'aimerais bien oui j'ai fait un stage
en italie de tir à l'arc ouais bah oui
mais c'était parce qu'un restaurant où
il faisait du temps c'est vrai on va
vous perdre offert du coup c'est quoi
votre petit tu l'as dans l'ailé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien j'adore ben vous le ferons
sans conseils 500 l'année prochaine
c'est quoi vous j la bamba
[Applaudissements]
et une vidéo de vous en cuisine dansant
sur la bomba gelé mais où il avait déçu
on voit rien du tout je n'ai rien
d'envoyer du tout dit la bamba dit là
bas c'est la doré 7 sur soi c'est vrai
moi avec plaisir mais qu'elle soit il y
avait aucune fin de soirée de fin il ya
aucune femme soit au dessus il ya eu
aucune jours en tunisie
on est à une soirée on était quatre à
dresser comme le tri car noël à l'étang
ton frère tu peux vous dire c'était pas
la folie nom lamouri tournoi call on me
voit pas
moi je me l'avoir sacs devant tout le
monde
emboîtant allez vous c'est en tout cas
c'est vrai qu'on me voit subreptice aval
c'est que votre dignité c'est quoi vous
et ben moi j'ai eu un immense coup de
coeur l'année dernière pour les trois
cafés gourmands
non
[Musique]
j'avais un ça va
c'est automatique 2007 c'est wes à la
nadal
[Musique]
alors non merci en tout cas stabilo boss
quand on est aujourd'hui merci à eux
merci vous êtes fait des extras la dde
merci chanson préférée de l'été je
comprends pas
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est la chanson l'été tu crois
toujours que tu vas pécho sur scène tu
passes toujours aux travaux de la mer je
connais tu danses comme un gosse mots et
tout est en fait bim tu la prend dans la
gueule je collais et vous c'est quoi tu
dis ça c'est un truc l'an un bébé c'est
que trois mois plus tôt son mondial en
anglais william p tit m à
non
[Applaudissements]